previously on model lifestyle
so here this is where AFI Fashion Week
is going to be
African fashion international
are you ready? I'm ready. Are
you ready? Let's go
So MAC are doing the makeup today
busy with the show now he's gonna send
me in the front
we're in the car here in South Africa. It's
very very beautiful and we are on the way
we're gonna do a photo shoot for you
guys. A male model poses for suits so you
guys can check it out on my youtube
channel now
these trees were driving past are called the Jacaranda trees. Check them out, look how beautiful they are
now when it comes to
expressions you have to imagine that
you're that person so imagine you're
walking in to a business meeting right
now you have that confident kind of look
sometimes they want you to be more
friendly more smiley more inviting so
then you think about things that make
you happy for me something to think
about is my wife
yes the photographer is also my
wife so it's like double points for me
anyway you get what I'm saying so
imagine that role it's a
little bit more like acting
my two brothers are buried here. Now
sometimes our lives look perfect from
the outside
but we all experience some kind of pain
in this world
my oldest brother he was shot in South
Africa when I was 13. Now my other brother he
died in a car crash when I was 21
losing them taught me so much about life
I also lost my father very recently to
cancer
I want you to know that if you have any
kind of pain I really have compassion
for you. I understand what it feels like
don't waste
your life because you never know what
day will be your last.
I made this video in the memory of the
greatest man I knew my dad Etienne
maritz